well you may not know it but we are in
the middle of a Bitcoin boom investors
are chasing various types of
cryptocurrency which is digital
encrypted money that operates
independently from banks verifying the
digital transactions is a process called
cryptocurrency mining it uses a huge
amount of electricity and this industry
is popping up in some unexpected places
in the latest CBS n original errol
barnett visits the small town of
Wenatchee in Washington State originally
known for its apple orchards now it's
the epicenter of a new industry mining
machines burned through transactions as
fast as possible and so powering them
and even cooling them down is half the
game
600
[Music]
right here
[Music]
while some in wenatchee are excited by
the economic potential of cryptocurrency
mining concern over its massive power
consumption and other risks is making
many uneasy seems like it seemed out of
nowhere like there's a lack of
understanding about
they like
my wife seems like
as much as she talks about it
so mystery to me nobody wants a fire you
know you know like their apartment
complex where it down because someone's
it's just going to drain our power
and that's all I know
I guess people complaining and
Harold Barnett is with us now Errol I
like how you had to correct him you were
thinking you were correct six home and
he's like no no 600 homes yeah but it
sounds like a lot of these people in
Wenatchee and I'm assuming people are
across the country don't even know what
cryptocurrency is how big of an issue is
that for local ther it's massive and so
what we saw is that a lot of farmers who
have had the same way of life for
generations see these containers coming
into town they hear the loud humming
these machines make and in some cases
for people who are mining Bitcoin at
home fires have started in the West
Coast you know how dangerous that can be
and the investors the true believers
behind this technology say look this
isn't about cryptocurrency and the price
of Bitcoin it's the underlying
blockchain technology which I'm
oversimplifying but is like a digital
receipt that you cannot edit they say we
don't even know the potential of this
type of technology yet and they believe
this infrastructure will bring them how
are they making money off this crypto
mining so when you mine cryptocurrency
you're basically taking these machines
these high processing computer chips
that are doing math and they are
figuring out ways to verify Bitcoin
transactions when you do that you get a
bit of Bitcoin in the bank and so it's
highly profitable the more you expand it
to scale but it sucks up a ton of
electricity and in places like Wenatchee
and other places they don't want to see
their electric bills go and they want to
protect that way of life so this is a
new frontier huge debate on Wall Street
and throughout the world now is this the
new currency or is it just another
bubble yeah Errol fascinating yeah we'll
be watching thank you
and you can see cryptocurrency virtual
money real world that Sunday night at
8:00 7:00 central on CBS n